for six years WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange has lived in the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London initially only
internet kept him connected to the
outside world but since 2016 that has
been taken from him
a man like Assange has a lot of enemies
of course but also friends and one of
his closest is actress and model Pamela
Anderson she has called Assange a hero
she says she now fears for his safety as
he has been increasingly cut off from
the outside world Pamela Anderson joins
us tonight thanks all for coming up hi
how are you oh really well thanks the
obvious question I can't was just asking
how do you know Julian Assange I know
it's kind of a funny pairing but I met
him through Vivienne Westwood Vivienne
Westwood is a dear friend of mine and
she's a great supporter of his and if
you knew that I would love his cause and
she thought I'd be great to meet him and
just and we get along great I see him a
lot I've known him for many years now
and he's a great testament to the human
spirit to be in a situation that he's in
and to have the is the fight that he has
in him Allah and the sense of humor and
he's really an incredible person
so it's it raises an interesting
question given what you just said why is
he received almost no support from the
entertainment world in Hollywood for
example well I think those are big
Clinton supporters and people have
misunderstood that his intention was not
to get you know Trump elected it was to
give true information so people could
make educated decisions about the person
they wanted to vote for so people want
to blame somebody and so they they blame
him yes I get a lot of flack for it -
when I'm in Hollywood so the idea is if
you support asan sure somehow against
Hillary Clinton in some cases you also
know Vladimir Putin do you believe I
said remarkably impressively
do you what do you make of the
allegation that Assange and Putin were
working together
it's crazy it's a crazy everyone likes
to blame Russia but anything goes wrong
in America and I've spoken at the
Kremlin many times and the last time I
was there there was something happening
and the first thing they say to me so
what have we done wrong this time
just it's kind of a common joke that
America likes to blame them for
everything so she yes I was with I was
with Julian before the election and he
had no no idea he really did not think
that Trump was going to win the election
but you know it turned out the way it
did some people she so you're speaking
at the Kremlin you're hanging with
Julian Assange the Ecuadorian Embassy in
London did you ever ask yourself you
know how did I get here exactly this is
the life path that you pointed well you
know I'm an animal activist I've been
you know an activist for animals and so
I was young and then I you know I spoke
about the environment I spoke about a
green economy in but vostok they invited
me to the Kremlin they loved the way I
was speaking and and I touched a lot of
people and so they really wanted me to
continue my my work in Russia and that
was just a coincidence I work where I'm
on the Russian Council of I fob which is
the International Federation of animal
welfare and and pardon me oh and so it's
just as a coincidence that I that I know
all these kind of crazy wild intelligent
interesting people so I know that you
live in France now yes but when you go
back but I think you have a home in LA
Malibu when you go back there and you
say you know I was just over at the
Kremlin talking to Vladimir Putin what
kind of response do you get a lot of
people are really happy about it because
he's made a lot of great improvements in
in my situation where I wanted him to
stop importing steel products to Russia
and that pretty much stopped the seal
hunt in Canada and that was my goal
initially and then to talk about all
sorts of environmental issues and you
know animals in captivity
you know capturing dolphins and whales
and and and not selling them to China
and endangered species we talked about
so I'm there to speaking with the
Minister of the Environment and and
people like that and of course there's a
lot of crossover because I just I have a
lot of causes I believe it and I believe
in just justice for all and a massage is
just an incredible person if you read
anything his mother says about him
that's a kind of an interesting source
to go to he's always been like this
since a child he's wanted to
you know he's been worried about doing
the right thing and I think he's very
brave and he's really in deep trouble I
think for his health and she's never
been into sunlight he's never been in
the sunlight for six years that's
already harmful and now he's been cut
off no internet no phone calls no
visitors and they're trying to squeeze
him I think out of there and one of his
only choices pretty soon is probably to
leave the embassy and he'll be arrested
and then then deported to America which
I don't think is going to be favorable
for him I don't even know what I think
of any of this but I think it's an
amazing and fascinating story and I'm
grateful if you shared it on our show No
thank you I appreciate it thank you